[Music]
thank you
welcome to wisdom for life where we set
through philosophy to find practical
advice that you can use in your everyday
life hi I'm Dan Hayes and today I'm as
always I'm joined by my co-host Dr Greg
Sadler and today we're talking about
misapplications of informal fallacies
and we're going to tell you what those
are in just a moment but we should talk
about why we want to tackle this topic
in the first place we're not just like
you know filling up airspace or
something like that we feel that it's
something important and I'll tell my
little story and then Dan can jump in
and say why he thinks it's uh
particularly important so with the first
one that we're going to look at in just
a minute I've seen so many people in
YouTube and social media
accusing people of it and and doing so
wrongly in a way that I think if it goes
on is going to make things more and more
confusing for other people and that
fallacy is called an ad hominem or
attacking the person we're going to tell
you about it in just a minute and so I I
wrote a little bit about this a while
back sort of complaining about it and
weirdly enough people jumped in and they
were like you're committing an ad
hominem right now and I was like well
that's really weird you know we should
get a handle on this and so then when we
took on this topic I I started thinking
about a dancer thinking about well what
are some other ones that people
characteristically get wrong and accuse
other people of in ways that are going
to lead to Great confusion so Dan what
about you what what are I I know you're
a pretty logical guy so you don't like
to see people committing fallacies to
begin with but is there more to the
story than that well I just wanted to um
disagree with you Greg because
um you're just a big poopy head
and therefore anything you just said
okay yeah
so you're illustrating the point right
there
that's a proper ad hominem that's
correct yeah but just to say that uh
something well
uh
anything on nice doesn't actually get to
that thing yeah like you you see
um bad arguments all the time people
make bad arguments
um and they often do it like totally
unaware that they're making the bad
arguments in the first place yeah and
that's perfectly fine and you know like
fallacies themselves
um art doesn't mean you're argument or
the conclusion to an argument is
incorrect and so oftentimes people will
will pull out these fallacies as a way
to try to end that conversation and say
well you had a policy and therefore you
know the whole thing is done um you know
you you failed you lost
um and the the it really kind of gets to
a lot of places where people want to win
arguments
when you know a proper usage of
arguments is for in a dialogue where
we're both trying to come to some true
conclusion and so the if you're
misattributing this into a really
antagonistic uh framework then you are
kind of going about this whole thing
wrong right
yeah so we're going to talk about
motives for doing this but we should
talk about well what what's a fallacy in
the first place and it's a technical
term in logic or critical thinking or
some other disciplines and we use them
to denote common forms of bad
argumentation that have an identifiable
structure so when we say that you know
something falls into a particular
fallacy we're saying it's an instance of
a general type of case and what's wrong
with them they lead people to who are
taken in by them to either accept or
reject claims that they don't have good
grounds for accepting or rejecting and
as Dan was just pointing out you can
actually have a true conclusion to a
fallacious argument and the conclusion
is still true it's just that the
argument doesn't get you there the way
that it's supposed to
um now you know the vast majority of
them are actually arguments and this is
coming from the Internet Encyclopedia
philosophy which has a a really nice
page on fallacies some of them wind up
being other things like they could be
like rhetorical tricks or just
explanations or definitions or other
types of things that we do in argument
and we're only talking about informal
fallacies here but there are also formal
fallacies where it's the very structure
of the argument itself you can like look
at it and chart it out and see how it's
it's wrong but the ones that we're
looking at are the ones that people tend
to do in you know ordinary conversation
or in debating politics
uh discussions about philosophical
topics
um persuading people to take their
medicine or not take their medicine or
pick whatever else you want I mean I
don't I don't think this is kind of an
interesting side note is there an area
of human communication where we don't
see fallacies
being used or arising or people falling
into them I can't think of any can you
no like yo
this is kind of like one of those things
from
um what uh Daniel Kahneman and Alex
trebersky like the whole like thinking
past and slow and like we have these
common ways that we we think about
things and that built into us at a
really low level that are really great
for saving calories but they also lead
us don't always lead us to True
conclusions sometimes it's a snake in
the uh the path and sometimes it's just
a stick but it's easier for us to think
it's a snake than it is a stick because
it will say help us more regularly
um
but I just want to like give a little
bit more information like you when we're
talking about a formal fallacy these are
like things like the structure and so
along the lines of like
um if a uh is equal to B and B is equal
to C then a is equal to C that is this
is a structure so this is again right
um all men are
um all men are are mortal Socrates is a
man therefore Socrates is Mortal
um these are yeah yeah and so that is a
a
um a valid argument
um structure whereas
um these are going to be things that
will still make the form of an argument
but they will not always lead to True
conclusions uh once again this is
assuming that all of the previous
portions of the argument on the premises
are themselves true right that's that
that's a good point to make now one
thing that we do have to say is you
might have heard of these by other names
because there isn't any one single
standard listing of the fallacies
sometimes we use Latin terms for them I
mean if you really some of them actually
have like Greek terms if you go back to
Aristotle but we don't typically use
those and then there'll be a number of
other ones so like appeal to popularity
uh could be odd pulpalum in Latin but it
can also be identified as the bandwagon
fallacy so depending on Whose website or
book or whatever
um you might get different names for
these but it's it's the
characteristic way of going wrong that
we're interested in here and before we
talk about motives for people doing this
um we should say like you know you want
to know more about fallacies so I've
already mentioned the Internet
Encyclopedia philosophy but you know you
can take classes uh you could do it
academically you could do it online
there's all sorts of logic and critical
thinking and communication classes and
resources there's textbooks out there
one of the great place to get textbooks
that a lot of people I think don't
realize you can go to your local library
and they will have these textbooks that
you can just check out and you know you
won't have any trouble doing that
because nobody else is checking these
textbooks out and the librarian would be
very happy to help you find them yeah
total side note too we should put in a
plug check out the books that nobody is
checking out because if books aren't
checked out after a certain amount of
time they they will be called for the
discard pile and they'll just
essentially go into landfills you know
they're not going anywhere else maybe
the library book sale but typically not
that so you're doing a public service by
checking out books right you're saving
them just says keep them in circulation
by circulating them yeah very good so
why why do people engage in or why do
people accuse other people wrongly of
engaging in fallacies what have you seen
Dan
you know
more benign and more not so benign
answers this
obviously they just don't know they they
heard about this thing maybe you know on
the podcaster or something and I someone
told them or just in conversation and
they they think something is what it's
not that's perfectly fine but then
there's other people that actually know
these and are actually acting in bad
faith and use these as like a rhetorical
technique in order to shut down a
conversation or to as I was alluding to
earlier to win the arguments right right
instead of actually trying to come to a
um a well uh
supported conclusion
I've also seen some people who seem to
be captivated by fallacies
and they you know sort of like you learn
a new technique or tool now you want to
try it out everywhere so you know this
happens to people by the way when they
take a critical thinking class I used to
teach lots and lots of sections of
critical thinking when I was at
Fayetteville State University and you'd
have to caution the students hey you're
gonna you know those of you who are
catching on because not everybody would
you are going to have this temptation to
see everybody talking as committing
fallacies which is is not the case
um so that might be something I I think
it's gotten worse with the
proliferation of what we can call
internet culture and how it's permeated
non-internet culture so like I would say
that places where
um
wrong diagnosis of fallacies are coming
up and then people are getting the wrong
idea about them would include like
Reddit or YouTube
um whatever I mean Facebook I see a lot
of people doing that there are there any
other sites that come to mind for you
where you've seen people
characteristically doing this this sort
of thing I guess Twitter to a certain
extent
right yeah that that would make sense
but I mean the danger here that we're
worried about
is that it's leading to a culture of
sloppy
misinformed applications of these terms
so if I if Dan says something and I'm
like that's an ad hominem man you know
and it's not then if you're listening to
this and you buy that now you're going
to use ad hominem that way and it sort
of cheapens the
they're at the bases the currency you
could say of our language that we need
to keep fairly
um
fairly real fairly
authentic yeah and and like this is kind
of in part like the nature of language
you know people start using it one way
and then that becomes the way that it
becomes used so for example
um
what is it uh
literally means figuratively now yeah
which is hilarious
um and then another one that we will
talk about a little bit later but I'm
begging the question
right
is using in the colloquial sense as
something totally different than what it
is actually when we're talking about a
logical fallacy yeah and I and I do
think we have to be
we have to be rigorous but also flexible
with this so like I'm begging the
question
um I originally was a real stickler
about this I now kind of feel like it's
gone so far that we're not we're not
getting the proverbial Genie back in the
bottle and we may as well just be okay
with people misusing that term and
recognize it as a a new use but the
other ones I think we kind of want to
hold the line right
um I mean are there any where you when
you looked over the list that we
selected you were like yeah I'm kind of
cool with people calling this this other
thing
I know
I don't know I'm still on the um this
raises the question if we're gonna say
big in the questions that's the logical
fallacy and that's the only thing we
should be talking about yeah that's true
when people are misusing it they're not
they're not usually using it to accuse a
person of a logical fallacy
in in the same sense as the original
meaning of it I mean maybe they are
saying well you're leaving something out
and therefore I've got you you know
so so why why do you think these are so
problematic I mean I think there's that
debasing the currency sort of thing
um it becomes difficult to to actually
figure out what somebody is meaning when
they're when they're using a word that
way but are there other things that you
think
are problematic oh if we're in debasing
the currency then we're in a good
company with a whole bunch of Roman
Empires here but regardless
um
I know yes I if we if we want to
actually come to better conclusions it
is very useful for us to
um have a a good working idea of of how
these things actually should be applied
um otherwise you're you're quibbling
over you know definitions and this is
definitely one of the later ones but
like you know we're we're trying to set
out the rules or the you know protocol
if we're talking about like computers of
how we actually go about a process and
if we're not using the same language and
processes then we're going to then come
to bad conclusions from this
so what are some other reasons why we
would find these false or fake
accusations problematic besides just you
know ruining the currency of our
contemporary language you know like for
example people say gaslighting now about
everything ignoring the fact that it
originally had a a real meaning what are
what are some other issues I mean you
brought up some of these before
yeah it was definitely the idea of
trying to root out kind of bad faith
argument and actors uh you know if you
uh
the entire Point as I said earlier to to
win are an argument is to just go
through
um and then point these things out but
without actually pointing out your own
arguments making actual good arguments
um then you're just tearing down and you
don't actually you're not saying
anything besides hey you're bad okay in
somewhere even if it's like in the
incorrect way of putting it okay so
let's let's jump into the first one that
we've already mentioned ad hominem right
uh and you know what it is is dismissing
a claimer argument that a person has
made because you call attention to some
negative quality about that person and
there's a Proviso there when that
negative quality isn't relevant to the
claim or argument or trustworthiness of
the person
oftentimes it's it's done in terms of
insulting the person and there there
could be cases where like if somebody's
a pathological liar saying well I'm not
going to believe the thing that you're
saying because you are a pathological
liar is not an ad hominem right because
you've got good grounds for dismissing
it but to say something like well you
know you belong to the other political
party so therefore what you're saying
doesn't doesn't mean anything or you're
just a gross you know uh foolish person
of this sort
um it we're essentially dismissing what
could be a good claim on the basis of
the the person and we could be saying
false things about the person or we
could be saying true things about the
person like I'm you know I don't like
people who eat caramels and you're
eating a caramel while you're presenting
this thing right now therefore I'm not
believing you buddy that's an ad hominem
right right
so you see this all like other places
just uh
not even in arguments but it's just like
hey like you're maybe you're
interviewing someone and they had they
could be really incredibly qualified but
uh they have some tick or something
they're just like I just I I really
dislike people like that and you totally
dismiss everything or the the potential
that they could be a good fit
um and so I guess that's true
um
so where we're talking about I've been
going what's wrong oh where people have
been going wrong with this is seeing any
sort of insult as just being an ad
hominem or even criticism so I I've seen
this in YouTube videos uh comments that
people will leave on one of my videos
about say Plato right and I'll say oh
you're you're wrong about that you've
got you've got Plato mixed up with
somebody else and then they'll say oh
nice ad hominem and I'll be like where's
the ad hominem in this you just don't
know what you're talking about and you
know I'm calling attention to that
um I I suppose in a very extenuated way
you could say well I'm dismissing what
they have to say but I'm actually
dismissing what they have to say because
it's displaying that they don't know
what they're talking about I'm not
saying
oh go ahead it's not just on the basis
of their arguments not of the person
yeah I'm not saying you stink therefore
I don't like stinky people and stinky
people have nothing to say about Plato
So I've seen lots and lots of people
doing this and I actually made a kind of
joke about it on the internet once I was
like
telling somebody that they're wrong
about something is not an ad hominem um
just insulting a person is not an ad
hominem now if I say that you're an
idiot because you don't understand the
use of ad hominem and therefore we
shouldn't believe you when you accuse
people of an ad hominem that's an ad
hominem you know so performatively
enacting one and right as you can guess
that did not go over well
yeah
and people get really defensive about
like these types of things it's like
okay
step back for a moment we're talking
about ideas and and if you are you're
taking this into yourself too much then
you're probably uh not focusing on the
actual important thing here which is
actually trying to you know work through
an idea yeah sort out what's what's true
and what isn't and I think that this is
the one that's at greatest danger at
this present time of there's like an
entire community of online mostly guys
who now dismiss people who are giving
them legitimate criticism or just
insulting them and they're doing exactly
what you were describing before they
want to win they want to defend
themselves and so therefore they Trot
out this accusation of ad hominem as if
that's that's now that you've committed
an ad hominem there's no more debate
about things right shutting down that
that argument and yes I didn't think I
was going to bring it but like this is
basically a fallacy policy okay because
you can explain what that is though for
a fallacy policy is a fallacy where one
says oh you have committed a fallacy
therefore whatever you were talking
about is now wrong it's like that's not
how any of this works
yeah I guess you're right the fallacy
fallacy could be looked at as a subclass
of what ad hominem traditionally has
meant right dismissing the claim on the
basis of something bad about the person
right
and then we could probably apply this to
many of these other things as well Ellie
kind of a base level because they're
misusing it in a way and then the the
output of it is therefore you know
your argument is wrong right yeah yeah
so is there anything else that you want
to say about ad hominem
in particular
besides that you you always look like a
scarecrow there right you know I really
want to just knock you down because now
we're going to be talking about a straw
man fallacy well you haven't gotten yet
to an ad hominem uh you've got to
somehow dismiss what I have to say ah
okay
um uh you you have no guts it's all just
straw
um you straw man therefore anything you
say is wrong
okay
uh very broad scope there for things so
straw man fallacy I think a lot of
people
are familiar with this this is when you
take somebody's claims or argument and
you you provide a basically a fake
version of it that's weaker distorted or
oversimplified and then you can dismiss
it right because obviously nobody's
stupid enough to buy this this crazy
thing that you've just presented so you
know we should come up with a few
examples that people can relate to if
you say that you shouldn't take a class
with Professor so and so because
they believe it's something that they
presented in class it's not even a
position that they they hold but they
were presenting at our Nietzsche's
position on morality right we should all
be Masters not slaves don't don't buy
into the herd be cruel be mean and stuff
like that and so you're like well you
know Professor George thinks that that's
how people should behave with each other
so nobody would believe that sort of
crazy crap right right don't take a
class with that guy I mean that would be
an example of a straw man do you have
any of that come to mind right away yeah
you see that in politics a lot so don't
worry
um I was like uh
um
hey maybe we should reduce the budget
for the military and then someone will
go back and return oh you want our um
you want to destroy America you want our
enemies to win
uh yeah or uh I guess another one would
be like hey let's um make a better uh
Social Security
um
net to you know catch these people that
you know sometimes fall to the crackers
oh you just want to destroy the economy
like you know it's it's taking something
that's really tangential to it saying
that's what your entire argument is
because that's a lot easier to knock
down and then you're like well
no sane person would possibly agree with
this yeah right
um or or you you see the that's just
communism or socialism all the time and
then you're just like yeah we'll dismiss
it because socialism is bad so I can
just whatever it is I I applied to so
now give it the label socialism it's
therefore bad and I can just poop yeah
so I mean this is a legitimate fallacy
people like you said do this in politics
all the time I think that you could say
people do this like when they're
comparing products if they're like too
closely competitive Brands
um and and we do this in all sorts of
other things I think this happens a lot
in personal relationship arguments so
what isn't the fallacy if you're
actually pointing out real weaknesses in
your interlocutor or opponent's position
that that you know are accurate
um that's not a straw man you're not
just
um misrepresenting their their argument
right
so it's easy to accuse people of having
straw man do you oh you just you don't
you don't understand what I'm saying
you're misrepresenting me
um I I think this is a Dodge that a lot
of people use when they've put forth a
bad argument to begin with they accuse
their opponent of
straw Manning them
and
what you should be doing is like I feel
you may have under misunderstood my
argument let's go through this again and
you're going to pull down like you know
individual points you're like hey let's
like dig into it that's the way that you
should be actually dealing with this
um but uh
I guess
we all often always talk about or not we
often talk about the kind of the
opposite of this is which is steel
Manning an argument where you try to go
through and give the the most charitable
understanding of an argument that is
possible but yeah you're absolutely
right
um when
um there are bad arguments and if you
can pull point out the wrong the things
that are actually wrong about the
argument
um that is not uh straw man in it it's
actually working through the argument
yeah and I've seen people I think and
I'd be I'd be curious to get your take
on this
um misuse steel Manning not in the sense
of accusing somebody of doing it when
they're not but rather calling for it as
like something obligatory or required if
you want to be uh discussing things in
good faith like I I don't think that we
always have to
distorts the interlocutor's position to
make it stronger more palatable or more
reasonable in some cases maybe we're
doing the wrong thing by Steel Manning I
mean it could be good to do that if we
don't really understand their argument
because is it what you're saying this
you know right but if if it's a bad
argument I don't I don't feel like we
have to steal management and I think
there's a lot of people out there who
are
acting as if that's incumbent upon us
but maybe that's just the circles I move
in are I mean are you seeing anything
like that or
I don't know if it's incumbent I think
it's a good uh strategy to try to use
especially if you're really unfamiliar
with a an idea or a uh like a whole
subject set of philosophy that you're
not familiar with it's like okay I might
be bringing a whole bunch of baggage to
this because I'm looking at these things
through certain paradigms or I might be
using language in a way so this is get
down to our equivocation policy I might
be using this term in this way where
this subset of of discipline it actually
means this and so you know if you're not
defining terms well enough really early
on then you might be making jumping to
conclusions about the arguments uh much
quicker than you would if you're kind of
slowly going through and trying to say
okay if you mean this do you mean what
do you mean by that right right yeah I
mean maybe also in personal arguments
and discussions like we know that the
person is generally a good person and
not arguing just to win points or
something like that and they say
something that seems really kind of
weird we could be like they probably
have just poorly articulated what
they're trying to say maybe we then
take the more charitable interpretation
So speaking of relationships I was like
I could think of
say you're having an argument with your
significant other and
um or and discussion let's try to be
more civil here
um
although an argument is not inherently a
negative thing right yeah
but to say it like to make this jump
from
um like
say you failed to
um wash the dishes okay and they're like
therefore you don't love me anymore
that that shows that you don't love me
anymore yeah I feel like this is like
okay you're taking a really fast and
loose like connection here and so
um just because I don't do the dishes
does not mean that I don't love you
anymore that is not the argument that
you should be doing here's
um so let's try to like what are the
better uh ways that we could actually
make conclusions about things what would
be the steel Manning of that well you
know as you're saying that I'm thinking
this is a great case where like if it
was a math problem somebody has skipped
a lot of steps right and what's going on
there is what we call implicit reasoning
there there are some other premises that
are built in that are the other person
buys they just haven't articulated them
to because to get from not washing the
dishes to you don't love me anymore
there's a lot of intermediary steps that
you got to go through but steel Manning
could mean you know suggesting are you
saying that because
this little thing here is connected to
this and this and this and this and that
leads you to this massive conclusion I
mean that would I think be a perfectly
reasonable thing to to do and if you if
you've got somebody who generally
doesn't say crazy stuff and then they
say something like that you probably
want to be like how did they get from
point A to point Z you know what what is
BCD all the other alphabet you know
letters along the way maybe you have to
actually go into Greek letters if
there's too many of them
so let's let's talk about another one
that I think I'm okay with at this point
which is begging the question now in the
past begging the question it's actually
got a Latin term patizio printcopy right
which means asking for the very thing
that you're you're using
um it's a circular argument argument
where you are assuming or smuggling the
conclusion into the premises that is not
the way that most people use this term
anymore we see people constantly
especially in like talking head news
shows or other opinion shows where they
say this well this begs the question
that and you're like no it doesn't beg
that question right and what they mean
is it leaves this question open or it
raises the question that I would like to
ask you now in the uh the show and
um
you know when we accuse somebody of it
as a fallacy I think a lot of cases it
we're just saying there's something that
hasn't been determined yet so it's not
really a fallacy when we accuse somebody
of it
um it's a sloppy use of the term yeah
I kind of feel myself like it's gone too
far there's no way we're going to bring
linguistic usage back and be rigorous
about this so I've I've gotten okay with
it you know it's still grates on my
nerves a bit you know I'm like somebody
should know better but
I don't know what what do you think is I
will I will take out my sword and try to
slay that storm that is enveloping me I
know that yet I'm not gonna be happy
[Laughter]
I just I just know that I'm not going to
be able to stop it but I'm not going to
be okay with it okay so you have sort of
the same position that I do but you're
more unhappy about it so to speak yeah
and and I I might still bring it up it's
like you're not begging the question
you're raising it
but when you do that because I assume
that you probably do do that
um how do people react
well sometimes it's okay and and
sometimes I get pushed back
um because that's the accepted usage of
it and that's kind of how language
changes and I understand that but
um I know even though you are
technically correct yes okay technically
it's the best sort of correct
what was that from I saw the drama
that's right yeah
so I saw somebody using that as a meme
recently
for me uh Hermes is a bureaucrat that's
right right the the head bureaucrat is
like you are correct are technically
correct the best sort of correct
yeah I I actually this is a total side
note I had some students because we were
talking about egoism in uh my ethics
classes my applied ethics uh classes at
Milwaukee Institute of Art and Design
and we were looking at like this notion
that some people have that like
everything people do is driven by
self-interest you know even when we're
like being nice to somebody else it's
just because we like being somebody who
is nice to somebody else and you can see
this guy's like you know eyebrows kind
of knitting and something going on in
his head and he's like I think we need
to talk about that as technical egoism
but not real egoism you know if somebody
wants to buy that position yes
technically everything we do is
self-interested because we have selves
but it seems really weird to say that
like doing something nice to somebody
else like you know buying them a pie and
bringing them the pie and letting them
eat that in front of you because you you
enjoy seeing them happy is somehow the
same sort of thing as like you know
bringing them a pie and then taking the
pie away because you you know you want
the pie for yourself these don't seem to
be the same uh class of of action and
motivation and I kind of like that we we
ended up using that term technical
egoism in the next class session as well
yeah and the question is like if that is
true then yeah why is it true that we we
are motivated by self-interest for doing
these nice things we do and I guess
the right oh what is it called the
reduction that I kind of pull with that
is that there's all these instances of
like what they call them Heroes there
was there's a
organization that gives out these prizes
to these people that do heroic Acts or
absolute strangers
um because they see them like you know
go off the side of the road or something
and they like run out of their car and
it might be
specifically going into places that are
dangerous like you know um where the
place with a whole bunch of bowls or
something and like pulling that out a
kid or there's a a fire going on in a
car and someone runs in there and and
pulls that person out
and like
if if I'm like really focused on my ego
why are there so many instances of these
seemingly totally selfless acts yeah
that for people that you potentially
have no connection to and a lot of them
people are total strangers
um
and like
it's a premise that works like at least
it gives
um
this this technical egoism gives you a
place you're like okay well
um it's good for me to work in a society
because or you know uh have a
well-functioning society with like uh
some good security and make sure that
people are are doing well off for
themselves because of you make sure that
people are prospering themselves there's
less chance that they're going to go
into crime which produces a society that
I want to live in more than like the you
know a Mad Max hellscape yeah yeah I
love that
it's about that well they're saving
somebody right
it's like well I'm gonna like sit down
here and be like utilitarians like well
what is each individual instance like
what's going on yeah happiness for
everyone so yeah
Peter Singer points out uh because when
he's talking about reciprocal altruism
right we're we're being good to other
people because we expect them to be good
to us he says that this doesn't really
work if people catch on to exactly the
sort of light and reasoning that that
you just articulated because they'll be
like well I don't know if I can trust
this person they don't really have the
right kind of motivation I want them to
instinctively or spontaneously respond
in a altruistic as opposed to egoistic
way and save me from the the
the river that I'm flowing down or
whatever it happens to be you know yeah
this is like kind of the reason why a
lot of people like don't give to the
people asking for money on the street is
like oh well I don't know if I can trust
them to do with that money the thing
that they either said they're going to
do or that I want them to do I was like
oh like that's out of your hands what is
the action you're gonna do right now
don't worry about like how it's going to
eventually come back to you is it the
right thing in the first place or not
yeah well coming back to fallacies so
another really popular one slippery
slope right and people will say oh you
know you're committing the fallacy of
slippery slope so what what is that
fallacy it's it's saying that one thing
will necessarily or inevitably lead to
another thing which will lead to another
thing and then at the bottom of the
slope you got something that's really
horrific so like you know if you either
there's that old Thing If You Give a
Mouse a Cookie pretty soon the whole
world blows up right well no you you got
a lot of steps along the way and none of
them seem to be absolutely necessary or
another popular one it certainly was
when I was a kid and I think there's
still people doing this if you smoke one
joint of marijuana you are gonna be a
heroin junkie and you're like how the
hell did you get from that to that well
you know marijuana is the gateway to
hard drugs and so if you smoke one joint
then you're going to want another joint
and then that's going to lead to
becoming a dope smoker and then you're
going to start hanging around with these
people and some of them are going to be
doing heroin or meth or pick whatever
else you want and soon you're in that
heroin Den you know shooting up every
single day stealing purses from old
ladies to feed your dirty habit okay
that that's a slippery slope fallacy
right
um and yeah you're absolutely right it
is still
prevalent nowadays yeah but there are
people who will accuse I mean we should
call out slippery slope fallacies but
there are people who will accuse other
people of anytime you say one thing
leads to another the like you're
committing slippery slope right and
that's not true to begin with there are
some actual slippery slopes so you you
know if you smoke a joint you're not
going to become a heroin junkie however
if you start shooting up heroin there's
a good chance that you're gonna that is
a slippery slope right right it's not
like a lot of people are like yeah I
tried the heroine yeah really fun but
wasn't for me you know I
I just put it aside or something like
that you know that's why we make a
distinction between
softer drugs like marijuana and harder
drugs like uh crystal meth or heroin or
you know PCP or things like that
um and then you know the the
there are cases where people are abusing
this
um but we don't want to we don't want to
just dismiss any sort of
um causal connection that people want to
to make we I guess we have to look at it
each each time kind of carefully are
these things really connected what are
the likelihoods right so it's just as
bad to say well this thing will
inevitably lead to the no the other one
it's just as bad to
falsely say that somebody's making that
sort of diagnosis well this is if you
look at like the scientific Community
there are two types of like studies that
can be done you can have correlational
studies or causal studies right and the
difference here is that there has to be
on one the the connection has to be much
stronger for us to actually put uh a
um
causal stamp on it and so for example a
classic example is that
um there's a correlation between ice
cream and shark attacks the more people
eat ice cream there are more shark
attacks there are the issue is look
that's not the Consular relationship the
causal relationship is people in the
summer go swimming
and people in the summer eat ice cream
that is the the actual causal
relationship yeah yeah and unless you
can actually prove that causal
relationship then you are making that
slippery slope fallacy but just because
one thing might lead to another well if
it is causal and ain't a slippery soap
fallacy that is just a causal
relationship yeah I I think too if we
speak in a qualified way
we can legitimately say okay it's not a
hundred percent that a is going to lead
to B maybe it's just 80 percent right
and then
um it's not 100 that that b is going to
lead to C but but C is really really bad
so maybe you shouldn't do a because of
the likelihood of it getting to
something pretty bad
you know like uh you could I don't know
you you might not really damage yourself
too much by drinking too much every
night
um you know like a nice six-pack every
day or something like that
um there are some people who do that
their whole life and they don't even you
seem to suffer a lot of cognitive
decline they seem to be okay so it's not
a hundred percent guaranteed but it was
a pretty good chance you know that if
you do do this thing it's going to lead
to this thing
um there's no guarantee you're gonna
have liver failure or burn your brain
cells out or anything like that and then
suffer this horrible end
um but it's it's a pretty good chance if
you're heavily drinking um all the time
not everybody can be Lemmy kilmeister
and drink a fifth of whiskey a day and
then you know only live into your 70s
and die of cancer which seem to be
unrelated to the drinking so
like your mileage remember but very but
yeah there's definitely a correlation
between these things it's like the same
thing with um
uh
was a high correlation like uh it was
smoking
has a high probability of you getting a
lung or
um
yeah yeah like yes it was a carcinogen
uh but not every person is going to do
it some people have really good genes
that allow them to you know get rid of
those uh cancerous cells all the time
you and I right now probably have some
uh smaller number of cancer cells in our
body but our body has
um
defenses notices when they start doing
weird stuff and kills them off
true yeah
but so you sound like you're speaking
from Authority here oh uh don't believe
a thing I say I am not Authority at all
uh so a an argument from authorities
asserting acclaimed is true because some
supposed authoritative expert says it's
true when the person's expertise is not
relevant yeah
there's a lot of people who will accuse
well they'll say that you've committed
an argument from Authority when you're
citing an actual Authority who you
should be citing right so a great
example of this
um would be I don't know it is in
textual studies if if I've got some
colleagues who are just like whizzes at
reading ancient Greek and they spent
their whole career on this sort of thing
if I defer to them and I say listen uh
so and so Anthony long says that this is
the case of Margaret Graver says that
this is the case and I'm I actually
think that they know what the what
they're talking about and then you come
along and you're like you've committed
an argument from Authority my friend
um no you're wrong about that they are
actual authorities now if I go to uh you
know Anthony long about diet advice or
Margaret Graver about I don't know
whether the Packers are likely to win
this season or not she doesn't know
she'd be the first to actually what she
would do is she would fix you with kind
of a glare and then she would like turn
her head a bit and then she would say
I'm sure I don't know what you're
talking about
so uh you know there are a lot of cases
where we do want to invoke authorities
because it's the right thing to do and
unfortunately in our culture and I think
there's a bigger problem now with the
internet
because of the proliferation of uh
conspiracy theories and distrust of
authority there's this tendency to say
oh you're um you're buying into this
narrative that the scientists are
putting out or
um that uh you know that the National
Institute of Health is putting out pick
up pick whatever else you want and a lot
of people will dismiss authorities who
are legitimate authorities and then go
seek out
not let's just call them non-authorities
because I was tempted to say something
kind of mean
um who confirmed the
the preconceived notions or biases that
they already have no right so yeah this
is definitely one it goes into motivated
reasoning which we talked about at a
previous moment I know well say what
that is though because people you've got
an idea a preconceived idea and then you
you go around shopping for information
that's going to support that idea
um and then once you find someone's like
oh yeah look there I've got proof right
there I've got evidence and that that
the whole thing works and yeah
um
and so the the basically they're making
this argument from Authority and says
like therefore hey an authority says
that therefore it's wrong you can't
trust the authorities which that's not
what it's trying to say it's saying
just because they are an authority that
doesn't mean it necessarily is correct
but the authorities especially in that
field of study are the people that are
most likely to know what the heck
they're talking about in the first yeah
and you know you could have authorities
even in a particular area where they'll
say I'm good at this part but I'm not
good with this part so for example I you
know I teach philosophy classes that
doesn't mean that I've actually read
every philosopherism as a matter of fact
I've probably read at best one
you know one tenth of a percent of the
available
philosophy books that are worth reading
out there and that's probably a high
estimate you know there's probably way
more people than that so if you ask me
about Plato I can tell you more or less
what he's saying am I as good as a Plato
expert who spends all their time doing
that no you know and at a certain point
I I just say well I don't I don't know
you know or I don't think anybody knows
um I had somebody asking me today about
the relationship between hegel's
phenomenology of Spirit and the science
of logic and whether they're connected
in this way in that way and I was like
buddy none of us know
people have theories but we don't really
know because the things don't map onto
each other that well and real
authorities will often use pretty
qualified language and this gets left
out oftentimes in in reporting and I
think that's probably a problem as well
that contributes to this distrust of
authorities because the authority will
typically be saying something like all
things being equal here's what the best
data that we have says I interpret it to
mean it probably
signifies this and then the reporter
goes out and says you know eating
oatmeal will destroy your brain
Authority says you know and you're like
that's not actually what they what they
claimed it's like we did a preliminary
study of like 50 people and we got these
preliminary data yeah yeah our
conclusion is that we need more research
because there seems to be maybe a
correlation here
um therefore you know this is the whole
thing of like red wine is good for you
red wine is bad for you coffee is good
for you coffee is bad for you back and
forth no one knows what the heck like if
you read the the science reporting it's
like yeah like yeah it's it's not quite
settled there's more stuff to be done
but you're jumping to conclusions and so
you're you're too young to remember this
because it happened before your time
when I was a kid eggs were either the
superfood that everybody should be
eating or they were gonna kill you and
it would fluctuate between those two
like every couple years and people would
like you know chew each other out they'd
be like I can't believe that you're
feeding your kids eggs at breakfast or
do you want to hasten them to an early
grave you know people would get quite
worked up about out this sort of stuff
and it was all coming from you know
reporting and now of course there was no
internet back then but it was reporting
in magazines and newspapers and on TV
and stuff like that so yeah I I'm
slightly aware of it but definitely was
not in the middle of it when I was aware
of things like that
um but I did want I think the egg thing
has died down yeah yeah
um is uh there is definitely room for
healthy skepticism like especially in
the scientific Community the skepticism
is actually a core to the scientific
process and the scientific methods does
not prove things it actually fails to
disprove them and so we don't believe
things because of scientific Authority
says so we accept the results of the
best data however the experts are the
ones that actually know how to interpret
the data and so if you're going in there
and you have like you know say you're on
a pilot and you you think okay you're
hot hot because you're a pilot and uh
you you go and read a paper that a
nutritionist puts out there it's like
well yeah you might know how to like fly
a pane and read all the uh instruments
and make sure that people don't you know
die when you crash and whatnot
but what does that have anything to do
with your understanding of what
nutrition science is at the moment
unless you start like really digging
into it
um a lot of these words might mean
something totally different than you
think they are and to feel that you can
come to an informed conclusion from the
just a uh a Layman's reading of a paper
um results in you probably having really
bad conclusions and so in this place the
people that have the best background and
understanding of these things are the
ones that can actually interpret it to
kind of like give you the the Layman
what they actually are meaning yeah you
know and then even if there is like
um a lack of consensus in a expert
Community
usually what you'll find is that if if
experts or authorities disagree and
they're all like actual authorities they
will be able to say what the reasons for
disagreement are where the dividing
lines fall and how you know the other
person's views aren't totally
unreasonable but they don't buy this
premise or this premise that the other
person does accept you know I think
that's that's a a good index for people
who really do know what they're they're
talking about so
um you know a pilot could disagree with
another pilot about how you ought to
handle a tricky situation where I know
lightning is hitting your plane or
something like that because maybe
there's three different ways of
understanding that you know but they're
not going to be like everybody get
parachutes you know something like that
this reminds me the end of most uh
scientific papers if you're putting out
paper when the section says what could
have you been wrong about what were some
places that you you might have you know
screwed up your experiment or data
Gathering there's a built-in like hey I
have to be yeah yeah kind of humble
about the things that I'm actually
wanting to talk about you know I will
say that's not ubiquitous in
philosophical papers or papers in
you know Linguistics or matters like
that but I have seen it's not done just
at the end in a formulaic way but quite
often
people will say okay so I've presented
this interpretation
um some other somebody might raise these
objections I think I can answer these
objections or somebody might have a
different way of framing this or looking
at this here's how I would respond to
that
and I I tell my students because
sometimes they're afraid to put that
into papers themselves they're like I
think I should present the strongest
case and I'm like no no if you can show
that you actually have entertained other
possibilities and you've ruled them out
for good reasons that is incredibly
persuasive and it shows that you're
you're doing your due diligence you're
actually being a critical thinker and
they're very surprised by that you know
well you know before you get to you know
the post-secondary level and it's like
you have to have the right answer and
that's the thing that matters but once
you're actually there trying to do some
research and you've got to like show
your work like it's like I guess in math
like you gotta show your work if you're
gonna come up with a good argument and
and really dig into it and show
everything
see now interestingly I was a math major
and I skipped steps all the time because
I could carry things out in my my head
and I really resented being made to show
all the steps
until I started making stupid mistakes
and then I realized why it's so helpful
to
um to
check all your work you know to show all
your work and then when I had to
collaborate with other people they would
be like how the hell did you get from
here to here and I'd be like well
there's this this this this and this and
then I realize it's just better to
actually show your work the whole time I
think that we're getting close to the
end of our time so do you want to lead
us out on a uh
final idea or passage
[Music]
um yeah I guess we're
and today's with the words of um Chris
jammy there's more to logic than
identifying logical alices
[Music]
foreign